[موسيقى]
بلا شك ان ما حدث
في هذا العهد من يعني
قطع لي دابر هذه التنظيمات عمل يعني
ممكن اربع او خمس سنوات يوازي عمل 40 او
50 سنه
فبلا شكل او قلل من خطرها همم اصبحوا
يتوارون لكن نقطه مهمه وهي ان الصحوه همم
جذورها وهمم هناك جمر تحت الرماد ما زال
ومن طبيعه هذه التنظيمات انهم في مرحله
الضغط والحزم انهم يكمنون حتى تتاح لهم
الفرصه الدليل همم هذا الفكر كما ذكرت
اساسه الفلسفه يمكن قبل همم اكثر من 150
سنه همم يعني على يد سيد احمد خان ومحمد
اقبال ثم جمال الدين الافغاني حتى جاء حسن
البنا والموجود واحياوا هذا الفكر مرت
الحركات سواء في المشرق العربي همم او في
ال- همم
الدول الاخرى في العالم الاسلامي مرت
همم يعني انكسارات ولكن مع ذلك تعود فهي
تعود وتتشكل وتلون لذلك يجب ان نبقى على
حذر من هذه التنظيمات وافكارها
[موسيقى]
همم نابوني في 80 سنه او بالتحديد عندنا
هنا يمكن 50 او 60 سنه ما يمكن بسهوله ان
تتخلص منها من طبائع الامور
كذلك ما اشرت اليه همم لابد ان يكون لدينا
استراتيجيه وطنيه تلتزم بها كافه القطاعات
الحكوميه
هناك او في تباين بينهم
وتوجيهات عليا همم تحسم الامور لكن مع
الاسف يعني ما زالت بعض الجهات همم يعني
لا اقول متراقيه لكن غير مقدره همم اعذرني
من ال همم لكن ما زالت بعض الجهات غير
مقدره لخطوره همم رموز هذه الجماعات
وخطوره هذا الفكر بالتالي يلزمنا
استراتيجيه وطنيه نلتزم بها جميعا
[موسيقى]